victoria you're next what's your
question oh hi hi victoria cute jack
yeah sure hit it um so
to make it brief i need help asking for
a raise
from my boss uh-huh yes so i've been
working with uh satay pawnee bakery and
restaurant so a restaurant in bakery
harlem brooklyn
for a while now
i'm basically like family i mean i've
known the family for a really long time
actually the daughter and i were in
choir together
and so yeah i started working in the
restaurant and then now i kind of in the
jack of all trades behind the scenes
and yeah i just i just feel like it's
almost the time it's just been that pink
elephant in the room and
yeah
how long have you worked there
um so officially since 2018 um but i
like through college would help them in
the restaurant and
in the back end of things but um more on
the marketing side since 2008 and
you when you started
um in an interview you worked on
their social media and content
strategies correct
now i think i understand
that when you came in
to now their social media footprint has
doubled is that not true it's definitely
grown a lot
yeah
that's important talk metrics but it'll
bore everyone
so we need to figure out how to get your
bakery to give you a little more dough
is what we need to do
yes i agree ross so who
who who would you talk to
um i would talk to my boss which would
be leia
yeah do you have leah's phone number yes
i do
you know what yeah let's call leia
okay i would use our flip phones but
they're gone
um well let's see oh i'm getting word in
my head that she's on the phone
right now hello
leah
yeah
hi leia it's drew calling
and i was just speaking with victoria
and i really hope that this doesn't kind
of catch you off guard or put you in an
awkward position but i was so inspired
by what victoria was saying about
working at your company and we were just
looking at the numbers and we were
seeing that due to her content strategy
and social media
um skills that she's been able to double
your social footprint and she really
wants to keep working there
and keep the company growing but
financially speaking she also wants to
grow herself
and so we were wondering if you would be
open to possibly giving her a raise and
compensating her so that she can
continue to make your company flourish
well first of all i'd like to say that
victoria is
is
a real gem she she's worked with us for
a long time satyapani would not be
satyapani without her
support and her hard work so
um absolutely i mean i i'm
it's an oversight on my part for her to
even have to come to you
so it's you know it's something that i
would definitely
be open to having a discussion because i
do know her worse
leah that's like the perfect answer
come
well thank you leia for being open to
being put on the spot
like this um we're all flying by the
seat of our pants but sometimes it's
worth going out there and fighting for
one another and
trying to help people's dreams come true
especially when they're working so hard
for them
yes
and i wish you
the best on your dreams you're doing a
family run business in tough times and
i'm sure it hasn't been easy so i
completely
um have empathy for that and i hope both
of you can rise up together
yes
oh i love that we're going to come see
you i'm going to come see you in harlem
too i'm going to try that bakery okay
absolutely thank you thank you thank you
so much
thank you
congrats wow
[Music]